foreign
is joining us now in Las Vegas how can
we help
hey how's it going guys good how are you
doing
good thank you what's going on so um
yeah so I have a question regarding
about buying a house so the situation
that I'm on right now is that right now
I currently live in Las Vegas and it's
just getting more and more expensive on
renting and
thing is me and my brother haven't
always been so close on financial things
about saving money together and
investing money
um the thing is he he offered me to buy
a house with him
so instead of him uh instead of me
renting a keeping renting an apartment
here in Vegas he offered me buying a
house with him and I will be paying the
house with
um the mortgage for him on the same time
the situation everyone is that I live
with my girlfriend and
um I don't I asked her uh what she
thinks about living with my brother
because it would be financially better
because
um you know he he's really he's really
nice about you know uh
payments together but
I don't know how to talk to her more
into it about buying a house and it's
it's that's my what was her reaction
when you first uh threw it at her
uh she wasn't really happy about it
because that makes her think that
um We're not gonna be really
um together
it's all horrible it's a horrible idea
relationally I'll let George weigh in on
this this is a new trend I'm seeing a
lot of George with people sharing
mortgages and trying to cut costs and on
paper you know it seems to make a lot of
sense but just relationally Alejandro
you need to listen to her this is an
awful idea I mean positively Dreadful
and I'm gonna speak as the guy who's
been married a long time uh
happy wife happy life and and this is
this is like uh this is this is
foundational like marriage 101.
um
this is just a dreadful idea I can't
think of a more awkward situation that I
could put myself in than buying a house
with my brother and having my girlfriend
move in and who's paying who and who
owns what who's the landlord around here
someone needs to fix that toilet yeah
who's vacuuming who's putting the dishes
up I mean it's just an absolute
relationship and financial Nightmare and
I get the heart behind it Alejandro
life's expensive you choose to live in a
high cost of living area and it comes
with the territory rent goes up and you
go hey on paper this is going to be way
better for all of us what's really going
to happen is it's going to destroy the
relationship with your brother and
you're probably gonna end up single
within six months
yeah those are the calls we get
I'm waiting we're going to get a call
this week and someone's gonna go I
bought a house with my brother and it
was a nightmare and now my girlfriend
wants to move out and break up with me
now Alejandro George is right but on the
other side of this is just patience
which isn't Fun
but you gotta wait you can't have it all
at the same time
and I think we've got a younger
generation and I'm just trying to be
really honest with you here
we want things that we just can't afford
right now and we don't want to wait so
we try to come up with a life hack and
buying the house with your brother is a
life hack that will hack your life up
what happens when you two want to get
married and now you got to move out but
he can't afford the mortgage payment
exactly yeah what happens when he wants
to move out now you're on the hook
because you co-signed
have we scared you enough
yeah you did
I don't want to be the boogeyman here
but on the other side you know I'm not a
fan of of people cohabitating together
before marriage and if you do want to
buy a house with her do it once you guys
are married
is that on the horizon for you too
uh it is right now it's just um like I
mentioned earlier she's not really like
the person who while he's talking about
money too much so for me is I do see
myself living with uh being with her for
a long time but I don't know really how
I'm getting mixed signals here I am too
how long you been dating this girl
uh for two years two years what are you
waiting on but you don't see a future
where they're currently because of the
money values yeah it's just the thing is
um like I really I talked to her about
money and stuff trying to
um
getting to like the uh the steps and all
the baby steps and I'm doing it with her
but we're not sharing money because we
both um we're she's still my girlfriend
you know I don't wanna no that's smart
but is she on board with this money
direction that you want to go
not really dude you got a dumper
no I'm serious as I can be dude you guys
have been together for two years and you
can't get her to see this Vision I mean
what are we what are we waiting on go
there go find some gal who loves you and
who is on the same page with you
financially this will rip your marriage
apart eventually and I just don't
understand why you would stay in it
this is a pretty big deal
yeah
I know it's terrible and then I'm not
trying to be glib we just crushed
Alejandro's dreams he was excited to get
a house
I disagree we did not crush his dreams
we saved you from nightmares here we go
I like that version listen Mary George
help me out here what does the data say
what's the number one cause of divorce I
mean money fights and money problems is
up there how can you live a life of
Harmony in marriage when you do not see
eye to eye on money you can't what
happens is they go well you keep your
stuff separate I'll keep mine separate
and we'll just split the main bills and
everything else it's my business and
your business
yeah that creates some intimacy real
quick Alejandra pushed back on me what's
gonna change what's gonna change to
where she all of a sudden sees the light
what needs to happen for you to go you
know what I I care about you deeply you
may even love her but you got to let her
go would she go through FPU with you if
we gave you Financial Peace University
would she watch all nine videos
yes I think she'll well because I've um
I've been talking to her about it and
then she's she's like the person it's
like yeah let's do it but at the same
time she's just you know forgets about
it the week after and I'm really trying
to get her more into it I don't think
she's forgetting about it but I tell you
this George you're much nicer than me I
think we give him Financial I want to
give him I want to give love a shot Ken
I do too but but listen if she won't go
through this with you and she won't take
it seriously you gotta dump that's a big
red flag
an Alejandro you're gonna be a homeowner
but you're gonna do it the right way
we're gonna have patience out of debt
full emergency fund good down payment
save 15-year fixed rate mortgage that we
can afford then we're ready to be
homeowners
until then it's a it's a cool dream and
I want that for you but man doing it the
wrong way will cost you way more than
the patience it takes to buy a house the
right way yeah